[Music]
d4 okay so what should we what should we
play let's go knight f6
what did dan do let's go knight f6 and
then we'll make a decision on the fly
nimso indian is a good is a good idea
kings yeah let's just play king's indian
i mean i don't know why i'm resisting
playing the opening that i play anyway
i want to talk a little bit after the
game about why i don't usually recommend
the king's indian to a lot of a lot of
players even though i played myself
but that's for after the game so
you've seen me play the king's indian
enough to where you should know that d5
is the grunfeld which i don't really
play
the king's indian
uh is defined by the pawn being on d6
you can play d6 now you can castle first
it doesn't matter uh you'll play d6 on
the next move it transposes there's no
situation which you don't castle and
chimpanzee plays a sort of a london type
of setup with c4 rather than c3 a little
bit incongruent i think
with the move c4
and um and i'll talk about those general
things after the game like minimum
rating and stuff
so
in the king's indian as a whole there
are essentially two pawn breakthroughs
that you're trying to achieve one of two
right and if you're not achieving either
of them
then you better have a pretty good idea
uh of what you're doing because 95 of
the time you're trying to accomplish one
of those fun breaks e5 or c5 and you can
play the kings indian with either c5 is
more of a benoni flavor to the king's
indian it's sort of a cross between the
king's indian and the bononi but there's
nothing in some positions you you only
want to go c5 in some positions you only
want to go e5 and in some positions you
can prepare either it's largely a matter
of taste
this is
a position in which both are acceptable
c5 is totally chill
um i actually quite like c5 here
and the reason i quite like c5 is
because white is playing in a way that's
aimed against us playing e5 so let's not
force it right we we don't necessarily
want to force it and white's got a lot
of different pieces staring at e5
so it makes sense to to strike with c5
and after d5 you get this sort of benoni
like position which i've also very
experienced then of course
okay and
already part of the reason that i don't
recommend this to a lot of people is
that there are just so many very
specific ideas that you have to
understand
and and here's one of them so i'm going
to make the move knight c6 which you
should be looking at this and saying
it's a normal developing move but if you
look a little bit more carefully you
might say well wait a minute aren't we
walking into d5 right closes the center
attacks the knight it you know don't we
not want to allow that move at tempo and
if you have played the benonian or the
benko gambit even for any length of time
you will know
where the knight belongs in such
positions
who can tell me where the knight belongs
in the event of d5 we're not going to go
there on our own will
but we're going to go there if white
goes d5 and closes the center not before
it can be chased away with a3
a lot of you want knight b4 but it can
just be chased away a5 a violation of
the rule that states that knights on the
rim are dim but in this particular
instances i'll explain after the game
you know we want the knight on a5 so now
we want to develop our bishop obviously
obviously we devil we could play bishop
g4 but then simply h3 so i like the f5
square here yeah
i like the f5 square we're also
preparing potentially knight e4 which
would open up the other bishop
another typical idea in such positions
to play bishop f5 and then knight e4
hopefully that makes sense and again if
d5 then we play knight a5
and we'll cross that bridge if we get
there
well then the knight h4 is not scary
knight h4 we can just drop our bishop
back to d7
and uh we're none the worst for wear
whereas white has a very awkward knight
on h4 so a3 by chimpanzee
is a decent move
what should we do now if you've been
listening
you already should be able to come up
with a good move
we're obviously our our plan is is
centered around putting pressure on
white center that is the
zen behind the king's indian so
some of you want to go a5 but that kind
of misses the mark of the position
uh
b4 is not a threat here we're defending
before enough times and a5 creates a big
hole on b5 and it also takes the a5
square away from the knight so it makes
d5 really really annoying and yeah the
typical idea is knight f6 to e4
this opens up the bishop intensifying
the pressure on the d4 pawn now if i
understand the mentality of some people
correctly you might say well i
understand that but
after 94 bishop takes e4 isn't the
bishop sort of vulnerable in the center
right can't why move the knight then and
attack the bishop and again this has to
do with not being scared of moves
because they create a threat
right and you always have to if you're
afraid of a move
you have to ask yourself am i afraid of
it just because it creates a threat and
in this case
that would fit the category because the
bishop from e4
can simply drop back to f5 it's
perfectly safe
white can't really take the f5 square
away from us thank you k sheezy for the
prime
does that make sense
the other good thing about this is that
after the trade we are then already
threatening to eliminate the knight
which would weaken the d4 pawn make it
possible to capture it
every ounce of fear has left my body 94
is actually a very hard move to deal
with in such positions very hard
how are we planning to on time in
exchange on d4 well we're not planning
to take on d4 unless we're basically
winning a pawn
okay chimpanzee takes
we take back
and i i think black is already playing
for a small advantage here
now we've we're spoiled for choice here
and there are some subtleties with the
variations that need to be calculated
already c takes d4 makes sense because
after cd4
ed4
bishop f3
bishop f3
knight d4 bishop b7 and who can tell me
whether that line does black of a move
at the end of that line don't stop
calculating rook b8 at the end very good
and you're skewering the bishop to the
b21 but that's actually not the only
move
we can also play the move queen d8 to b6
putting
massive pressure on white's center which
i like almost as much as cd in fact
maybe i like it even more
there is a subtlety here
which is that c takes d4 allows knight
takes d4 but then we can take and go
queen b6 so i think we're we're in the
clear we can play cd
we can play cd
okay ed and we can go down the line we
went upon and our strategy has been a
success now we need to
reorient we won the pawn we're
chilling
i mean maybe chimpanzee missed that
after bishop b7 rook ba just can't stop
calculating right you got to calculate
as as far as you can
we win the pawn on b2 which also ruins
why it's queen side pawn structure
creates ideas of 92
this is really
just bad i mean why it's just down a
pawn for for no compensation at all
well if white plays b4 we don't have to
why would we give away the b7 button
it's our move right we can take the
bishop
and then play like queen d7 and defend
the pawn
okay yeah that's what happens now we
definitely want to get this bishop all
right why does the bishop play that
maybe is
his only asset right now is the bishop
bear so let's eliminate it now you might
say well isn't the knight good in the
center it is the 994 is good but so is
the bishop so i think it's a fair trade
i think it's totally a fair trade
now we need to defend the b7 pawn we can
do it in a variety of ways we can play
b6
um that's totally chill
we can also i like moves like queen d7
because they also connect
right this move also connects the rooks
and when possible you want to achieve
more than one thing with your moves
so queen d7 defends the pawn
and now we're ready to get our rooks
into the game rook ac rook fd8 seems to
be a pretty logical follow-up probably
rook fd1 is going to happen
although
rook fd1 actually creates a threat okay
recap e1 is not scary i mean
this this pawn on e7 is perfectly well
defended so let's uh continue improving
our position with rook ac8
i actually missed uh a little detail
here but it it really isn't the end of
the world even if he plays it
i i missed a slightly annoying move here
let's see if chimpanzee can spot it
queen e4 he does
he does um i i wait no he doesn't
queen e3 would have been better
attacking a7 and e7
not a double attack that we didn't have
an answer to we could have gone e5 there
but that's not a move i really wanted
him to play queen e4 only attacks one
pawn
so we can obviously defend it with rook
feat but i didn't identify undefended
pawns didn't follow my own advice
rook c2
somebody asked if we're playing for b5 i
wouldn't necessarily go for b5 you know
b5c takes b5 is kind of annoying
so we've got a gazillion different ways
that we could play in this kind of
position
we can play it sort of slowly or we can
play it for a quick knockout
i like oh i love the move queen a4
that's just been proposed
i i love queen a4 because it puts the
queen on a great square it attacks the
pawn it pressures the rook
and it it just pressures white's queen
side
and it makes you know white has a very
hard time defending everything here
because you've got all these flimsy
pawns all these weaknesses the rook is
vulnerable
queen a4 looks like a phenomenal move to
me
and you can also play for a7 a5 here
this is a classic idea trying to get
this pawn out of the way so that you
increase the pressure on c4 that's a
good idea to note down
a5 in this position we can actually play
it
we can also play b5 now that the c2 rook
is under our
um
watchful
gaze
but i love a5 i think that's such a
thematic move in these types of
positions
such a thematic move because if white
takes then white ruins the queen side
pawn structure if i goes b5 then white
justifies our queen placement
and then we can use the skewer against
the bishop the x-ray against the bishop
to make a very nice tactical move i hope
he goes b5 okay
goes ba
now if we want to be really fancy here
we have a super
interesting move
but i i don't necessarily know if we
should play it
we have an interesting idea i'll show it
after the game i don't actually think
it's the best
yeah d5 so some of you are spotting a d5
and whichever way white takes you win a
piece if takes of the pawnee when the
rook it takes for the queen
actually the rook hangs in both cases
but d5 is not so good because white can
play rook e to c1
and you've bitten off a little bit more
than you can chew so
i prefer
well actually let me think about that
for a second do you fibroxy one
it's it's certainly very tempt actually
no i do like it sorry i i do like d5
there's something i noticed there we can
do
it's also just a sexy move so
i'm kind of biased
[Music]
this has not been an easy game
a lot of instructive positional ideas
here
okay rook c1
what did i notice
what how can we continue our initiative
first of all first of all we we can take
on c4
and then take again and then take a5 and
we're up upon like we we can do that as
a backup option
but i kind of like the idea of starting
to push the center bonds going d4 and
then e5 and trying to shove e4 through
and we can start with d4 that's actually
a very tricky way to do it
you might be like wait a minute i don't
understand what was the downside of
going e5 first but this is just sets a
trap right
there's nothing wrong with switching the
move order because our opponent might
not realize what we want
and might play a move like queen back to
d2 or something and then we go e5 e4
with tempo but bishop d2 is correct very
good
now we expand with e5 and if we can go
e4 the game is basically over if we can
get e4 n
there will be hell to pay
at f3 we go f5 anyway that's a i mean
white is a very strong move here which i
i wonder if he'll find i think white is
only one way to defend everything else
is almost lost
white is only one way to defend here and
it might actually put into qui call into
question or my entire idea but let's see
if he finds it
okay he doesn't so he plays bishop b4
and this allows us to shove this pawn
down the board of the e4 now our pawns
are just tearing white apart
right chimpanzee focused on defending
his queen side pawns which didn't need
defending rather than stopping the big
threat at hand which is our central
expansion which is totally crushing
queen e4 was the defense queen e4 just
putting the body of the queen in front
of the pawns okay what should we do now
how shall we proceed just keep it simple
make the most obvious move yeah just d3
running this forward and now we have
tactics everywhere
now we have tactics everywhere
we're actually winning the rook
so think about what we're going to do if
he plays rook d2 because there you have
to look at the whole board
and if you look at the whole board or if
you make the right types of observations
you should spot the move very quickly
right any time the rooks are aligned and
you have a bishop of that caller you
should be looking for pins that's a
no-brainer now here
first thing i see is that we have a back
ranker if the rook is gone from c1 so we
have rook takes c4 but this is a great
and very instructive example of not
automatically playing a move just
because it looks good
i think there is a move that's even more
clinical than rook takes c4 which
literally wins the rook on a2
which wins the rook on a2 queen b3 right
it's not gonna win you a brilliant
surprise but it wins the rook because
rook d2 again there's bishop h6 or
there's rook take c4 right rook c4 is
not going anywhere
so i'll show oh rook c4 actually
threatened brook takes b4 so maybe in
that case rook takes c4 was also good
no rook c4 was more accurate i'm wrong
but it's fine i i didn't see that rook
c4 also threatened rook takes b4 which
won the bishop but this is also winning
still the fact remains i think that it's
still an important point
which is to to look for the most
clinical continuation
and resigns
okay um a an instructive game for sure
good game chimpanzee thank you for
volunteering to play i appreciate it
okay
so how do i formal verbalize this what
is the reason why i don't always
recommend the kingston first of all i
would put a rating minimum at like 1600.
i think anybody below like 1600 or so
shouldn't even consider playing the
king's indian because it
i've explained this before
you can't break the rules until you've
learned them you need to spend some time
learning the rules
and the kings indian is an opening it's
a hyper modern opening that breaks basic
rules of controlling the center
allowing white in the case of a four
pawns attack just massive control over
the center what i often see when like
people in the 14 1500 range play the
king's indian
is just like
they really struggle to understand
the basic ideas and
there's nothing more tilting than
playing the king's indian not knowing
the ideas because you just get crushed
every time
white just shoves the pawns down the
board and you feel like this opening
sucks whoa chimpanzee with a 10. damn
girl
thank you for the 10 subs i appreciate
it
can you can you make a brief comment on
why the four pawns attack is fringe well
if you know how to face it the four
pawns attack is not dangerous although i
wouldn't call it fringe it's it's one of
the main it's close to being mainstream
so against the four pawns attack is a
good example of where you can actually
play e5 here that's a pawn sacrifice
line
but the accepted line is c5
the accepted line is c5 and then
basically playing this like a bononi
and white's center is somewhat
overextended in the in like the
theoretical lines
so
according to theory the four bonds
attack does not present any objective
difficulties but it's still
a viable weapon
yeah this line of bishop f4 is not very
dangerous
and but but just to finish that
discussion
you know when you hit like 16 1700 you
get to a point where you can start
considering playing the king's indian
and the other thing that sort of stands
behind my
coldness toward the king's indian is the
fact that i i don't recommend for
beginner and intermediate players to
play cramped openings in general i think
it's important to under to
get positions where you're not cramped
and
to learn to use space it's again one of
those things you need to learn to how to
use space in order to learn how to be
cramped
and you guys know that i play a ton of
cramped position i think i'm good at
that
but it's because i've had so many years
of experience in the king's indian thank
you riley pool fan
and you
have to accept a lot of cram position to
play the king's indian
so anyways now that i've like crapped on
it for five minutes let's take a look at
the game so bishop f4 is not the
greatest line
chimpanzee because the bishop is on a
fundamental level is just biting on
granite here
which openings are not cramped well
anything other than the kings any queens
gamma declined which i played
exclusively the first half of the
speedrun
which is why king nimzo indian
even the dutch um is a little bit less
cramped than the king's indian although
it's borderline
and the england yes love queens get
accepted
that's why i recommend the queen's game
of decline as your first opening until
you're like 14 1500. before you even
think about
playing a different opening
that's that's my recommendation
you have to make an investment
in terms of being able to play these
boring positions you have to suffer
through it
and then you will reap the rewards
tremendously as opposed to starting to
as opposed to saying i want to have fun
right away and then
setting a rotten foundation like the
question is are you in it for the long
term so okay anyways
hopefully the the rationale behind going
c5 makes sense
um
if you wanted to prepare e5 obviously
you can't do it immediately right that
blunders a pawn
so one
factor in the king's indian is that
generally the b8 knight is developed to
d7 you generally unless it's the main
line you don't go knight c6 very often
although in this particular instance
knight c6 is totally fine in fact knight
c6 is probably the best way to do it
because if white plays d5 you have the
intermediate move e5
another reason why bishop f4 is not a
very good developing move because it
walks into e5
yes definitely
so after knight c6 let's say white goes
bishop b2
and this is another thing that i see
inexperienced kings indian players do
all the time they love going rookie 8
but rookie 8 is actually very often a
bad way to prepare e5
it's an something that
sounds weird right what could be wrong
with it well let me show you after
castles
e5 still doesn't work the rook is
overloaded when it's on e8 because it
also has to defend the queen so what
often happens and i see this blunder so
many times is after queen takes in
you're like [ __ ] like you know i have to
take with a rook
and then you give up the pawn on e5
or take with the knight give up on e5
so
you'll see
experienced king's indian players often
go queen e8 precisely for this reason it
looks awkward but it's a better way to
prepare e5
um another way to prepare e5 in this
position is to move the f6 knight back
to d7
which is a
type of line against the london this is
called the armenian variation you
prepare e5
and
then you can also go f5 which is a very
typical king city move thank you simon
okay so we want c5 which is much simpler
to play
aven asked why not dc so dc
is not dangerous for a variety of
reasons
you probably are aware that queen a5 can
be good in some of these positions but
here we would play dc
you've opened up the bishop
and black's bishop and position is just
more equipped to handle
the open center
because we've developed the bishop to
such a nice square
i mean what what could possibly be bad
about this end game for black this is
just a great position
and white is not castled and if white
goes bishop e2 you can start
various shenanigans like queen b6 and
rook d8 or you can just develop knight
c6 bishop e6
pressure c4 i mean
black has no targets the bishop on f4 is
neither here nor there
so
i mean this is just good for black
so bishop e2 is fine knight c6 and this
is another thing right d5 you have to
know that the knight belongs on a5 in
these positions
why does the knight be long in a5 well
first of all it pressures c4 and in
conjunction with
this benco gambit style idea the knight
is actually very good on a5 here and the
benko gamut style idea that you'll see
very often in the fianchetto for example
is a6 the other that which is the other
line or the knight lens on
on a5 so in the fiance kings indian the
traditional main line
is to play knight c6
and then
the the sort of most popular line
nowadays it's not the line that i play
but it's super popular is to put the
knight on a5
and i i've done this before like i put
the knight on a5 before and then you go
c5 of course you have to be careful
about b4 and games have been lost when
people just for forgot about
b4
but that's just
comes with the territory
so yeah the knight in general the king's
indian you often use a5 as a transit
point for peace this is one of those
things that you just don't know unless
you're very experienced frankfurt
airport i have the greatest frankfurt
airport example if you guys want
this is from my tournament where i got
my first gm norm it was a fian kettle
king's indian he's playing the spanish
gm cabrera alexis cabrera
rook b8 is the line that i
used to play a lot and the point is to
prepare a6b5 but it's a very very
flexible move so h3 a6 so here white
decided against going d5 he played a
different line
so he allowed me to go e5
and after d5 b4 counter attack in the
night
so
at first i go back to e7
and then i went c6 to open up the center
but in this position
who can tell me what i did i made a move
that i was very very proud of after the
game like i found a maneuver that i
thought was was really really strong
so the knight on c6 may not look bad but
it's sort of not doing anything it's
staring at a square that's already well
protected
so where do you want it
where do you want it knight a5 yeah
knight a5 where is it going so first i i
decided to complete my development i'm
not rushing to get it away from a5
but now i get it to the square i want it
to go b7 and c5
and that night was an integral part of
what ultimately won me the game
that same night later on in the game
once i broke through in the center
went to e4
and it finally sacrificed itself on e4
but not until white was down a gazillion
pawns
so a good example of using the a5 square
as a rerouting point which is very
different from what we did here
which is to use the a5
square as the final destination but
nonetheless i just think it was a this
example came to my mind
and uh back to the actual
game we would get this position which is
a little bit different but the ideas are
the same you want to go b5 and you want
to go benco gambit style in many cases
you just go b5 anyway
you sacrifice the pawn and then you go
bishop a6
and you develop play on the queen side
anybody who plays the banco gamut will
recognize this this is very familiar but
you don't have to sack the pawn you can
also prepare it with bishop d7 and rook
b8 and try to induce the move a4 and the
move a4 essentially makes it impossible
for white to ever go before so the
knight is now safe
and it weakens the b b4 square so
sometimes you'll see these ideas
sometimes you'll see black pushing e6 or
e5
trying to get white to take so that the
knight is freed up
very positionally complex situation
anyways i i hope that makes sense
um
[Music]
chimpanzee didn't go d5 castles bishop
f5 a3 i think is a serious inaccuracy i
actually think
sorry i actually think d5
should be played d5 and knight d2 i
think is the way to play this with white
and the bishop is a little bit
awkward on f5
so once white doesn't play d5 and we go
94 the pressure on the center becomes
tremendous
and the problem is that the train has
left the station because if you go d5
now
you open up the bishop and after knight
a5 the pressure on b2 is really hard to
stop i mean you can still go knight t2
bishop f5 you can chase the bishop
around but now black is in great shape
to play a6 and b5 so
um and and we don't have to go knight a5
we can also go like knight b8 here but i
think even this was better than the game
continuation because once you allowed cd
you're already in trouble
after 94 what if d5 well d5 knight c3
same concept but now white has a ruined
pawn structure
or you can go knight b8 yeah knight b
and knight z but i like a5 because
you're pressuring c4 so
once this happened you're in trouble cd
yeah and if knight d4 then we don't go
e5 that's a common mistake right knight
c6 like counter attacks the queen and
the bishop can move
um
sorry but knight d4 you play knight t4
ed and then queen b6 attacking two pawns
at the same time
right
so once we win the pawn
it's bad news
bishop b7 rogue b8
and then we win b2
yeah and this is just bad so
next important moment
one thing i wanted to point out before
we get to that moment what would have
how do we stop c5
so white threatens c5 because of the pin
what should black do against it and this
is what i call type 2 prophylaxis
i've talked about this before on stream
type 1 prophylaxis is physically
stopping a threat type 2 prophylaxis is
taking the sting out of it you allow the
move but you prepare a response to it
and people are not as good at type 2
reflex yeah rook fd8
right now you're not stopping c5 but
you're preparing the move d5 which
renders this totally
ineffective
engine says equal here interesting oh
well because of queen e3
yeah yeah i know that makes sense i
blundered queen e3 which is a double
attack against the two pawns and of
course black can save the pawn by going
e5 but that is a serious positional
concession you're blocking in your own
bishop
although maybe black can play f5 and
turn this into a classic king's indian
pawn storm
so it's bad this way and that way and
the other way but queen e3 was i think
the best chance
once you allow me to defend the pawn and
get my queen to a4 i feel like things
are going downhill rapidly and the last
chance for you i think was
to go queen e4 here
or sorry in this position to go queen e4
stopping e4
once you allow e4 it's over
but here i wasn't exactly sure what
black should do because if i go queen c6
white can actually take and then you can
start harassing my b7 pawn
and this gets very double edged like e4
rook b7 and white gets a far advanced
faster on a5 so
it's not entirely obvious what the
evaluation is here
in any case once you allow e4 it's it's
over what about f5
well f5 blunders the b-pawn
and you can play e4 here but it's come
at the cost of allowing a past eight
bond so this is getting really spicy
again
so black maybe should defend the pawn
with queen d7 then white continues to
harass black with rook beyond i wasn't
totally sure what to do here
so that's why i was skeptical about d5
but we decided to play it anyway just
because it's an instructive move i think
so
anyways once one c4 was allowed the game
was the game was over
so any questions
before we wrap up for the day
have a great night everybody i'll see
you in ohio
later
[Music]
you